hey everybody and welcome to the Shan
method I'm Sean McGinnis this is chris
waters hey Chris were you aware that the
month of May is video game history month
in the United States of America and also
every country in the world the entire
universe somebody our universe yeah and
yeah in celebration of old as hell games
uh-huh that may be held a trouble engine
games you know games that are really old
and we're cool at the time but maybe
haven't aged all that well we're gonna
play pokemon snap pokemon snap yeah what
I know the game where you just take
pictures of pokemon for fun well yes
okay but isn't is that not the ultimate
commentary on our modern-day condition
where we just walk around taking
pictures of Pokemon people from fine
shore Instagram yeah indeed you know
it's just it's a scathing before its
time indictment of our celebrity culture
and deep deep voyeurism absolutely let's
play 15 year anniversary this game came
out in june of 1999 wow yeah that was a
memorable month for young Chris waters
that was when you graduated from high
school Needham High hey those are ones
of high school that's weird stalking me
what is your name here it'll come on I'm
gonna name my character jerk yours a
good name okay oh alright Eric Eric is
how you premiered its its Norwegian do
you know one of the directors of machine
games the studio that made wolf entire
Wolfen Wolfie times three times the new
order order his name's Eric Eric spelled
like jerk that's pretty tight yeah the
game is tight too alright so this guy is
making a like a Wikipedia of poker games
the reason I invited you here is this
pikmin report I'd like for you to take
pictures of pokemon for the postman
reports Jim and here on Pokemon island
wild Pokemon can be found ever
where this is my new invention the 01
vehicle a real basic ass bucket reveals
on you can date a strip 01 vehicle
constantly moves toward the goal gate
shall I repeat this information Chris No
thank you no thank you I'll teach you
how to take pictures in the first course
I'm counting on you jerk uh he's real
salty yeah he's really motivated is
assaulted at you doing that little yeah
i'm the dude who's got the stripe shirt
on with the weird red hair what a sunny
beach it looks great i should get some
awesome shots there let's go beaches are
one of the top five Instagram bubble
places on this planet yeah so one can
only assume that logic its tends to the
poke a verse yeah i mean i would
certainly think so fressy to aim oh you
shouldn't pudgy Oh piggy press a to
shoot shoot all these birds I'm not that
was a good one shooting so many piggies
try to take a lot of Pokemon pictures
all right give it a shot all right one
thing holy crap yeah that doduo is out
of control and you missed it this is
good Pikachu shot right here oh wow
that's a three-fer come on get a hat
trick Oh mondo do smile smile do a pika
dance I thinking she was bored as hell
yeah yes he's very confused this is
surfboard Oman yep the water-type
pokemon that just hangs out on the sand
pet doduo is just it's gonna it's
waiting to evolve to shroom that's a
mantra that is that was not a pre
evolved tomate have some respect for the
source material Chris that is not a
Mothra that is a butterfree just doing
its thing let me now be this oh that's
tubbo is the ultimate shot I call this
Snorlax crotch that is a snore a bunch
of your shot if I ever saw one that I'm
rude you ever wonder what a snorlax
couch looks like wonder no more no more
for the information now exists in your
mind all Meowth is trolling you oh yeah
what up now so as you can notice I'm
using what historians refer to as a film
camera okay that uses I can see that
film icon way up in the top left corner
and he was 33 films left already got
some new pics at me out they're gonna
consume that Pidgey oh yeah he's
definitely trying to feast on its
delicious in about gold which and my
loose understanding of the Pokemon
universe is what me elf does oh
definitely yeah alright where these
sweet Pokemon whoa Pokemon ate that tree
was gonna pop out our there's another me
out that's clear Cudi oh that's clear
Katya the deforestation haha he's a
deforestation type Pokemon uh folks I
join us in making up goofy Pokemon names
in the twitch chat at switch w /
gamespot or in the game slot comments
already we have some comments are saying
that the player character kind of looks
like me hey does we're gonna have to
reassess that 00 like a what is that
rolling Boulder Evie Evie yeah is that
is that it oh is that might be a ditto I
don't know oh my Kangaskhan Kangaskhan
is a pretty good name for a coupon hey
Kangaskhan quick teabagging those
flowers and give me a good shot that is
where kangas cons go to do their biz oh
do you think I get more for taking a
shot of him jumping in the air yes oh
that's uncalled an action shot I wish
the reticle on my camera was a pokeball
oh it is a pokeball it's gonna attack
whoa-oh action shot actually shot of me
out trying to eat the unhatched children
of piggy Oh No ah I had Marshall your
tricycle bucket has reached the
teleporter it's called this zero
something I forget what it's called all
right let's see all how all these
pictures turned out you know that it's
cool are you see it costs a lot to
develop photos I forgot this is film
processor oak better be subsidized I
can't just pop the SD card out of my
camera and then pop it in my laptop no
just lightroom either take it to a
walgreens buddy oh right look at all
these let's see what Oaks mark is are
you ready yeah i'll choose which
pictures to show to Professor Oak oh but
I want to show all of them listen you
just gotta choose one of your Pidgey
pics i think far right all right yeah
that's
that's a pretty dope should I show this
yeah yeah that's a good picture I have
decided to show piggies picture sweet
five pictures of Pikachu I think that's
look closing his eyes a good one Pikachu
entering a fugue state what the [ __ ]
that's surfboard Oman the water type
non-canonical I like this one cuz it's
poetic he'll just grunt he's cresting
over a ridge in the distance but you
don't get that sweet detail in the wings
it's true this one employs the rule of
thirds yet does do you think professor
oak is down with the rule of the herds I
think he's way into it what that's nor
lacks taint no you you got I should get
like doubles foreshadowing Snorlax is
the final boss of this level where you
try to get to a position where you can
take a picture of his entire Gooch yeah
that's true I feel like I should use the
the later one of me out where he's like
being murdered by [ __ ] that's probably
cap when birds are beating is up yeah I
choose this easy I choose that
kangaskhan yeah I looks pretty good or
this one yeah the owners been knocked to
the ground yeah this is it here is a
dead mouse to look a picture of me
health corpse and then this dude doduo
perfect all right to Professor Oak here
we go show this pictured Professor Oak
yes I believe so hi twitch user soon
filf seems to be confused about which
one of us is Sean and which one of us is
playing i I'm Chris I'm not playing i'm
sean i'm playing i have a controller in
my hand it's just in his lap so you
can't see it in the stream now for the
sake of clarity this is a Nintendo 64
game I just want to illustrate the
inception reality that we have entered
into okay yeah so we are using a wii u
what to emulate a wii to emulate a
nintendo 64 to play pokemon snap
nice yes because we live in the future
and such if you're using a wii u to
emulate a wii u can't actually use the
gamepad for some dumb as hell reason you
have to use a wii remote with a classic
controller oh you can't use the wii u
gamepad now you can't use the wii u
gamepad yeah we had some people in the
chat wondering about you like it would
be cool if you could use the wii u
tablet to like look around yeah that'd
be great no no no no no just throw that
dumb idea out of your head outside oh
you're gonna get rated on size 310 is
only so-so what is Professor Oak's scale
this is 310 out of a million Brooks
transparency is really not 7 750 is so
so that's three times as much not it
more to what two and a half times as
much and he doubles the score because
the Pokemon is in the middle of the
frame clearly that answers the rule of
thirds question ie he doesn't know what
the rule of thirds is yeah Professor Oak
you go back to being a professor and not
a photography critic for those who don't
know what the rule of thirds is actually
it's a photography technique in which we
r you to take the frame of say this
screen or your camera viewfinder and
draw two horizontal lines one at
one-third down one to two thirds down
and then two vertical lines one at
one-third in one and two-thirds in there
four intersecting points are actually
the more aesthetically pleasing places
to place the subject of your picture so
whereas you're doing a family portrait
you do it straight on sure that's all
well and good but you're trying to take
some pictures something make it look
pretty make a look a little gymnast
acquah ish yeah as they say the rule of
thirds rule of thirds perfect which is a
rule that Professor Oak most definitely
does not subscribe to all right use the
rule of thirds and you can be smarter
than Professor Oak but probably less
handsome because let's face it he's dead
that dude is rugged as hell yeah yeah
800 points all right see I think 800 is
when it stops being so so and getting to
all right yeah and that's when you get
to all right yeah but Professor Oak he
doesn't not he doesn't share a lot of
like generous feelings with people he
plays it pretty cold yeah because he
doesn't want you to get too uppity I
have an alternate theory Sean ok
Professor Oak is a gamespot commenter
thanks you need to get eight to be kind
of Sosa to be all right Oh topical my
pokemon isn't in the middle of the frame
see it would have been better if it was
right in the middle I'm gonna bash I'm
gonna mash through it I Professor Oak is
a fickle mistress we know that already
we don't need to waste any more time
smashing buttons these are all good oh
cool ah quick call back to us clarifying
who each of us is Duncan Hornsby informs
me that I just missed the joke and it's
a joke to the fact that Danny and I have
subbed on this show multiple toe oh yeah
fair enough okay a couple times super on
point yeah this goes you were close but
you see it it disappoints poke about it
be photographed from behind note to self
Pokemon don't like butt shots Professor
Oak is not a poke a ass man is Professor
Oak would prefer you to avoid the Polka
Dot stuff jeroque wants full frontal or
nothing I took so many pictures and I
regret it I reread everything about it
alright let's see it I'll save the
results of today's trip in the pokeman
report wait jerk let's return to the lab
oh that was a good day that was good saw
the pictures taken by jerk I saved those
pictures in the Pikmin report I'll help
you out once you have more Pokemon
pictures good luck jerk good luck here
let's see it how did we do my sadness
time war has been going on for longer
than the snapping part what's my best
shot he had his eyes closed photo by
jerk technique that's nice that's nice
he's right he's Mac dab in the middle
all right let's go back into the wild I
hope we unlocked a new course of a sub
oak press a to do it the jerk can go to
the next course tunnel junior cast 84
thinks scythe was the pokemon in the
bushes maybe the ones rolling around
also you missed Lapras next to the
Kangas gone says is otay in the gamescom
that in the background but uh I
definitely couldn't get yeah I
definitely uh did you just run over
Pikachu well you're getting real close
to that electrode that's the gas Oh get
that freaky cat Oh action shot Oh nerds
electro thingy Electabuzz electabuzz not
taking over thought got forgot forgot
restrain yourself my bad oh man he's
poking on her rough really Oh no ha eat
it in turn max says it's scyther in the
bushes you would in turn max he's
actually an awesome duties about works
back there makes the graphics look all
cool come on explode and apparently
knows a lot about Pokemon yeah who would
have thought or just read the chat
better than I did yeah I'll get it oh
well you stop zooming in your failing
because it's hard it's hard all right
come on nuts get it get at least a
decent Pikachu huh I got to uninvite
these controls it's too much even a
thing ya get come on egis or hash hats
you piece of [ __ ] hash yoga p i need to
get my baby my abilities this is a
coughing us that thing is all over the
place all right you are zoomed in I
don't think that's helping you can you
take a picture when you're not tuned in
all right you're going through the door
new era a new area to area new area I
wish this had a quick 180 button I would
make my life Resident Evil 4 yeah like
[ __ ] left 4 dead style oh shiz head
re for controls oh and liked electabuzz
trying to get into the research facility
do you want me to take pictures of your
dumb cat but apparently uh electabuzz is
well known to believe this time big line
is a glacier now that diglett is gone i
take 100 its back yeah look at that hot
diglett action that's one of main
pokemons you can't say that about
because it the way that its appearance
is if you ever want to suffer emotional
trauma I recommend doing a google image
search for diglett with safesearch off
let's just say many people have been
interpreted him as a penis I should
throw that out there come on take a
picture of magnetar come on what is that
thing fair enough
one electrode you're gonna you're gonna
explode or what Magnemite sorry folks
pop off pop off oh he doesn't like it
when i zoom in it get him get the face
Oh too shy I see I can't take a photo
from here I gotta do my dirt them off
Magnemite are well-known babies they are
such little turds oh oh oh it's over
it's over I think you did much worse
this I think I did that one was not
quite as rich with new pokey man's
camera check how many pictures have you
taken 27 pics all right I can use the
album ark to save my favorite pictures
in the album let's go mark them off show
oak what you got that's a good one yeah
that's really exploding off yeah he's
popping off big time is not gonna have
some good technique yeah maybe should I
even bother marking the ones of the
elect buzzes but you need I mean you
gotta get something I gotta get some
points right and at least as but is
roughly in the middle of the frame there
do that oh that is a great picture of
Zubat that super super good picture of
zoo grey framing oh look at all the
pokemons in here that's I think diglett
is right in the middle here oh yeah
that's a good shot that looks like
Pikachu is worshipping diglett here's
another really blend middle picture that
Professor Oak is gonna love because he
hates genre pushing photography
professor oak is not exactly an
avant-garde no photo critic no then
again this is for the pkmn report that's
not for such photo journals as
photojournalist monthly or sounds like a
real thing the snaps snaps pokey times
monthly hmm what's new this time this is
electrode oh it exploded Oh 12 Hondo
points yeah yay
run man playing pokemon it's so so wow
what only 50 for the pose oh yeah cause
it's the butt stuff ya professa very
very clear about his proclivities yeah
Professor Oak is a man who suffers for
many personal foibles but a penchant for
butt stuff is not one of them often
naughty in the twitch chat feels our
pain he says we're we're pretty stifled
working for professor professor oh yeah
yeah he does not let your creative
creativity shine let's just say that Oh
picture versus picture i think this one
yeah so so i can i can double that for
you okay the pokemon is right in the
middle of the frame i can double the
score ah oh dear you're getting worse oh
dear professor what if professor oak was
like your dad and you had to deal with
that your whole life mm-hmm do you know
traumatic that would be I mean on the
one hand sure it gives you like a pretty
fast track into the career of being a
Pokemon master but on the other hand the
deep-seated issues of inferiority and
never being good enough would probably
undermine your personal relationships
for years to come if I get 5390 more
puts on my pokeman report I'll get
something cool what do you think I said
it's pretty cool I bet at some cool [ __ ]
I bet bag that it's a goat of course
flash there used to be a power plant in
this long dark tunnel I can't wait to
check it out you know where is a dope
place to take photographs long dark
tunnel long dark tunnels gammon oak uh I
got to go back here at all right locked
in getting your your trike oh snap all
right let's get it put a Pikachu on the
books for good measure I know that one
of these dudes is gonna explode in a
second it's the same one come on get up
there and is this the same level oh yeah
I got to go back cuz uh I didn't I
didn't unlock the new course cuz I did
kind of a shitty job okay yeah alright
so you need to be way more on point yeah
there's gonna be uh is this where the
zubat is
no get one of those thingies ah come on
get a thing or pot there's another one
get it ya khuda kakuna Matata nice yeah
all right nailed it whoa I should have
got the group show yeah probably I think
there's a diglett on the left coming up
or is that next through this next or
another electrode nards laying on his
butt electrode all right I got tasting
kakuna do it get it oh that might have
been a little better [ __ ] is fast yeah
[ __ ] that zubat use accelerate on the
track you were chasing this thing the
whole last time yeah didn't get the rap
out of it get it oh ? it's not revealing
its true nature to you [ __ ] you Pikachu
sorry that was rude he didn't deserve
that get it yeah I nailed it that wing
I'm gonna have an amount of points
you've got two new ones man you got the
car gosh totally totally whiffed on the
zoo be doing and I really screwed the
pool right I told you to square up on
this diglett real quick and got you two
going on this [ __ ] to get into that
diglett and just really just lean it a
[ __ ] just get down on a diglett get
down on it all right here we go all
right I don't know if any of these are
better than my last one he's got to be
real close here oh yeah Joe does rio
this is a much better run for a young
and Sean McGuinness yes you can really
see his situational awareness blossoming
after taking this course one time
through I think we're gonna see some
really special scores come out of this
one with the new pokemon know about
practice Chris yeah what is that weird
constellation of things I don't feel
like that would be where a Pokemon would
go all right can you get one of these
long long shocks no cuz they know when i
zoom in freak out
damnit magnet thing you bunches of dicks
yeah you think the trick is to judge no
dude dodrio is a bunch of dicks you
gonna explode now it's gonna sit there
looking snide it says you are the worst
pokemon besides jinx you know that cuz
you're just a pokeball oh man get it oh
come on why you stop doing that come on
it's good it's got a Tucker itself out
eventually if you take a photo now it
doesn't work it's just am peeing your
camera it is that is like a chap come on
what oh sure Paui calling back to
yesterday's ball players stream in super
classy fashion the dugtrio is a real
runaway train using the phrase correctly
I mean you really have to ask Tom mcshay
but I believe you are well done great
that was real good moving on are any of
these shots of electabuzz not like a
weird but shot one just show him the
cocoon no cook kikuna no mikata was this
a good whoa whoa whoa snazzy dragon says
you have to throw an apple at the last
electrode oh I haven't got the apples
yet maybe that's the something cool
you're gonna get the ability to carry
apples that's replayability that's
replayability where they don't let you
do all the stuff the first time through
so you have to go back again and do this
stuff again is that really the best
kikuno picture you got snot you were
better I think you have a better zoo vet
all right you just definitely have a
better zubat this time around that yes a
money zoo that that is big-time money
zubat Haunter what the hell is a Haunter
i guess it counted that thing it was oh
look at that I'll take it I need to look
it up what a hunter is this is a sick
magic harp yup hunter is just a poison
ghost use your splash attack Magic card
which one of these niglets should I use
yes CJ vibe 01 also suggesting the apple
throwing in the game spot comments thank
you folks we will try I believe that's
something you have to unlock them to go
Chuck apples as soon as we unlock it
alright which one this one I think oh
look at them all in profile or do you
think do you think this one oh she loved
it is this one better that one is
getting her photobombed by Pikachu or do
I get more points for it being
photobombed I think this is clean yeah a
good clean shot yeah I choose this I
think that's all yep it's all the poking
man's to Professor Oak yeah these
monster is the evolution after ghastly
before gengar duh duh who doesn't know
that well she I do that I don't know
that I didn't know that let me see this
is Pikachu yeah not as good as my
classic Pikachu show not as good as the
year but has like a weird thing in it
yeah Wow the size way better well nicely
done look at that okay killed that one
you definitely kicked out his electabuzz
another junkie electabuzz shot from
someone who couldn't give two craps
about taking a decent electabuzz shot
Sean sorry that was harsh i was a little
rude house a little Hakuna Matata 250
nope not good this is all gravy though
is he not gonna he's gonna give you the
bonfire for putting a rope your work is
impeccable impeccable we're all over the
place oh alright impeccable we'd have to
see a much higher score ok Pokemon is
written is friend yeah technique is what
gotcha yeah time huh huh lon turds out
the window
you are close Magikarp using a splash
attack 430 how's the pose it splashed
that's good what do you want now is
how's the pose oh it's flashed it's
black it's flat it splashed 800 points
yeah how's the technique okay the
pokemon is right in the middle of the
frame and it's splashed I can double the
score for you wonderful your work is if
I think you might have unlocked
something cool I think so oh we got to
get the diggle diggle daga land here a
bagel I think this gonna be better than
my last one yeesh you were very long wow
wow what made this so much worse it's
not more away yeah alright dugtrio this
is a money dugtrio this is money come on
505 all its size as the pose it's trying
to go underground one yeah as the
technique double it yeah nice 3,000
points yeah my work is impeccable keep
up the good work that's the only time he
will ever give you positive
reinforcement is if your work is
impeccable cool sky man wonders how some
can someone work for a game company and
not no asterisk asterisk asterisk about
Pokemon I think you could watch this
stream I clearly know at least one
asterisk worth of pokemon stuff ah but
now we're not poking experts and we
don't claim to be I learned about
Pokemon a lot when I was a high school
because oh that's why he got into a
career in Pokemon education cuz he you
know you like would you like to be
closer to poke a bomb mmm i think maybe
Professor Oak has gotten a little too
close over the years and that's why he's
got that crazy in his eyes he does have
a little bit of a electrode thing going
on there I'm gonna hit yes that you're
just gonna hit the only but then use
this appleshaped Pokemon yes so known as
apple
it's easy to use when you are not
focusing your camera press a to throw it
how many apples do you have pokemon in
the distance will happily come closer
when you use this item if you want to
throw farther look up slightly then
throw here's a hint for you throw some
pokemon food to an electrode that's not
moving oh I bet select road near that
wall is gonna like blow up or something
I bet we're gonna have to do this thing
again aren't we same track the tunnel
track yeah thank you go to the chorus a
to do it I bet he says that to the
Pokemon before he has sex with them good
of course I see where you're going oh we
got to do the tunnel on a third time you
could do it but i feel like i got like a
quick you're in a real good groove with
tunnel yeah one more tongue cuz we got
to get the okay so we'll be right back
after a brief commercial break at which
point we will have decided beat your
tunnel cast your votes now see in a
minute hey buddy we're back what's up
pokemon snap the fight for the perfect
photo continues we have unlocked the
apple shaped pokemon food also known as
an apple and we're going to take it too
we have decided the beach yes the beach
because as in turn max tipped us off and
as tillage in the twitch chat has also
suggested you can get the pokemon to the
surfboard to do some pokey tricks yep
Pikachu's going to do some sicky tricks
a poke a trick is a trick that a Pokemon
does yeah all right you can probably say
you want to practice your apple throwing
yeah eat it oh god I'm so used to the
inverted controls that now it feels
weird just get on use to it all right
you got to leave the pic the pikachu at
you too far too far throw it right in
his face no I already got you oh he's
coming he's coming Pikachu you need rail
come on apples all right I think it's
gonna turn what up it's coming over here
be getting very anxious
oh yeah standing look at those hot pics
i took the piss he's a little too far
away it's gonna be pissed oh yeah all
right you already got a pretty sick
Mothra we're ma for before whatever they
call it listen I don't mean to sound
disdainful of Pokemon when I say their
names wrong I just think it's funny I I
respect pokemons even though I don't
rank you're a dumbass great knowledge of
them I'm just like I'm going to town on
his junk but he's just still sleeping
listen you're gonna need something
stronger for Snorlax all right you look
out for that kangaskhan thing that was
showing you the butt all right that's
not a good bugger got to be facing
forward I probably shouldn't have
uninvited my controls I got used to them
within those 25 minutes you fool I made
a huge mistake where's the kangaskhan
you need to make it turn around it's the
right one come on stop live come on out
oh yeah yeah but I was pretty solid me
out
good thing i have unlimited appleshaped
pokemon food where's that deforestation
type open DeForest Oman come on
all right I'm gonna get the the big was
it Genghis Khan google icon goodbye con
yeah Kublai Khan nailed it hooble I
kangaroo come on eat my Apple [ __ ] get
it wow you are your doduo game is yeah
it's not great weeks not good yeah suck
it meows oh man yeah here is a picture
of some pokemon abuse that I did what do
you think about that oak wait till you
wait to your closer all right what if I
threw one over here so that he comes to
eat it got a beam him yeah just make it
rain there oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah nice
that's no that is beautiful beautiful I
mean we all done hell of additional
points now who just knocking piggies out
of the sky oh wow did you use grow
apples in the water thanks in turn max
yells in turn max oh I turn man thanks
for nothing man thanks for nothing yeah
sure I'm sure it did something oh he did
everyone is saying how apples in the
water not sure that water okay should I
have done it sooner twitch chat oh yes
that what we're going with now in an
earlier lake apparently
it's a good one or is it too far away
should I go work with the earlier I
don't close better clothes size is
important to Professor Oak yeah size
matters to that prima donna see none of
these are as good as my earlier butter
fries true now you're gonna bother this
one is probably better could be a better
meal I got two in that shot that could
be better just give it a try yeah this
for my comparison now this is where
things really get good I think that one
that one yeah yeah that's a pretty
awesome one all right let me know what
you think showing off to Professor Oak
oak town USA time for you to present to
Professor Oak surfing pikachu yeah oh
yeah 300 points that could be better so
so how's the pose this is very lively
sly Valley SDF as the technique double
double damn well done picture is much
better than the last one yeah thanks to
everyone who suggested that yeah but
this is better he's right in the middle
but it's also not an action shot his
pose is I mean he's jauntily crossing
the road that's an improvement yeah that
was a net improves out it there's two
butter freezing this one I'm really
banking on the double Butterfree level
trouble 320 uh is not gonna know he'll
work this is already a lost cause nope
it's disappointing to have a Pokemon
photograph from behind yeah I know here
we go money shot yeah II think that is
that the best size score you can go this
all out of a thousand maybe this angry
shot is pretty cool a thousand right in
the middle well booboo for that I went
from 430 to 4000 let's just say
everything is coming up milhouse mm-hmm
yeah in this metaphor are you an email
out or I'm ill how okay to be clear
there's a hidden path in the tunnel good
luck jerk that oak man he is this real
salty salty dog all right I guess we got
to go to that hidden path in the tunnel
oh yeah who's ready are you ready what
is the hidden path I forget what it is
do you have been 15 years since do we
have to do something special to get to
the hidden path or will he merely go on
to it I know you know what I think it
might be uh being a electro dude
electrode with an apple that one that's
sitting near the those glowing Rock ball
all right you need to get a better
picture of this this dude yep all right
pretty solid pretty solid out of the way
Electabuzz you to try to get a better
cop I'm gonna try to nail them that's
what I'm gonna try to do you're gonna
try to nail kakuna finger matata you're
really where's giving her a bunch of
them oh and not even okay there we go
they might come back down yeah oh he's
so sad oh sad town he's so sad I told
you the cocoon or coming back down you
hurt away to beam Cypress being intro
does all I know how to do straight beam
intro'd get you the road what's down
here anything good anything good in
there I'm gonna be in this egg is what
I'm gonna do yeah yeah keep it up now
you probably have to use some other item
that we don't have yet like a laser like
I'm loot or like an ar-15 probably
what up magic coat ah didn't even I need
to conserve my shots I'm going a little
crazy here yeah all right let's see I
got it we're good right I think you can
take another shot at an elective buzz
try to see if that thing responds to
apples probably doesn't know it's an
apparition apparitions don't need
pokemon food it goes right through it
all right yeah that's not gonna be
better than surfing is you can shoot i
guarantee you that all right try to get
a better Electabuzz here hey I like to
get you what are you doing face eat it
like the buzz you still got all he's
coming at you oh I'll get the TV get the
TV picture doesn't matter always give me
a hint telling you to throw an apple at
that thing yeah throw it into the thing
throw it into a weird place what's going
on in there ain't nothing is going on
something's going on over there all
right mark my words to the right look to
the right beam him all right vinum
yeah hidden path oh yeah boo boo Boop oh
now it can stop it can't stop when I
want to take a good picture Chris why
are you looking at it so fondly I'm so
shocked what oh yes they can fly that's
a game changer mutiny look at this damn
it oak alright time to see what my best
shot was I feel like I got some good
Electabuzz improvements I took a lot of
pictures I probably took too many
pictures this is not gonna be better
than my action shot gerdes that's a
that's a solid one I feel like he's
facing but I had him doing other stuff
earlier here's the group one that's not
that's not even registering his kakuna
it's not look it's comparing it to
electrode this could be a good one
that's what he's really close that would
be a better one if oak was down with the
rules third yeah that's true which he's
not but we'll just rub it in his face oh
this is a good one that is money that is
money money that is money in the poke a
bank this might be better hey kind of a
wash may as well find out uh I don't
even know what this one this is a
Pikachu show yeah that's a not to chew I
feel like he's doing like electrocution
[ __ ] here maybe but he's also not as
close it's not as not as big and as we
know Professor Oak likes it big like
some big the subject of the photos I
just I don't ya know what also bring you
guys know yeah I'm gonna go this unless
i'm gonna go with this got out this
slightly open it's got an apple and it
does have an apple in a shot but do you
think oak gives it two shits about
apples now AKA pokemon food you don't
even know what an apple is should i go
this one now i feel like that super
close one let's see how he does with the
objectively cooler shot most effectively
from my objective viewpoint ah we're
gonna go to oak let's go to oak let's go
to the loo
Professor Oak's check mm-hmm what do you
got what do you got ah close though
close solid you gave that photo more
credit than I thought you would've yeah
all right yeah it's gonna be way better
yeah you ready for this Oh guys listen
big improvement here folks oh yeah
double leg time big timeline on it yeah
you are all right zubat you are quite an
up-and-coming snapper here Sean ah not
quite not close this close we're the
shot you're right better write it was a
pretty much a wash all right I like the
buzz now that you're turned around so so
technique well there we go much better
oh yeah much better yo D Magnemite think
was the first one on record yeah not I
grant the best one but we've certainly
done better but hey as a technique créé
solid actually not bad really the size
you can stand to improve 2180 what is
that you gotta you have more points for
having more in the picture yeah your
work is impeccable how come we didn't
get that with the dough did there was
another 1i God trio is what I know he's
one but there was another situation
where like there was I don't know never
mind wait jerk let's return to the leg
hey let's return to the rotten jerk oh
yeah welcome back when you're gonna get
one of those story cutscenes this game
does have a rich narrative you should go
right away of course I say to do it yeah
all its volcano time you ready to meet
some [ __ ] charmanders cuz we're
about to
you think there's some charm Anders up
in here yeah I definitely what about
like a charmeleon maybe now that's no
definitely did you forget Lapras again
yeah we should we sure did Oh what the
hell it's coming did another one coming
rapidash throw it into the volcano come
on alright look forward come on there's
nothing it's never gonna be the perfect
run on the first go Chris get it get a
single shot on hole pics oh I see sure
as hell yeah that was nice get off the
track alright now throw those thing into
the lava all right now you go into the
lava yah bonk mmm bonk oh did I hit it I
think I hit it you get out of the way
turn to the left no you're derailed by
bull mixes this is plugging it this this
isn't good get out of the way it's real
it's gonna be some mangled vulpix
wreckage on this track God or vulpix the
trick is to throw apples every which way
that echoes miam John's suggestion into
twitch chat throw apples pretty much
everywhere throw apples basically
everywhere just have it littering this
entire joint with apples take a picture
of magmar lookin a hell of dumb come on
over here magmar you dumb piece of [ __ ]
oh yeah be angry yet a Charizard he's a
Charmander sorry get it together
craigslist gonna need you to not
embarrass yourself any more on this too
late
whoo here we go this is gonna be good
what's happening Oh Moltres well done oh
here we go no I'm this time around oh no
you present it yet don't you as bud you
know that Oh ain't down with that come
on quick we're presenting its get over
here that's some good char mandarin oh
look at that they are yelling like crazy
in the back I only got 92 whoa holy
Charmander yeah party I just interrupted
a Charmander swinger parties what I did
now death that's what I'm talking about
all right yeah get one in there now put
it in the other one given the other one
i think i got to get all through all
these terrible shot all right think you
got in there come on nope all right I
got it all three ain't nothing happen to
lace too late anything here Oh magic car
[ __ ] you magic harp hit the charred
thingy Oh Gillian yeah you're right here
is a charmeleon roll with some lava oh
nice he's gonna come out of the shores
are ya get it no oh no
oh the charizard was right there I ran
out of [ __ ] [ __ ] you film cameras oh I
had a Charizard in my hands but hey if
you hadn't gone buck wild on those
vulpix I did really go to town on those
vulpix a--'s that's ok cuz we got a lot
of new pokies yeah we got a lot of we
got some exciting stuff uh let's see get
a raggedy probably this one it's in the
middle go that one get a repeat ish ray
P dash creepy too nope no no no you get
way better vulpix is yeah there we go
which of these I can tell which one is a
vulpix and which one is a this one it's
real happy yeah thats good one middle
yeah that's a good job this one's pretty
good i think there's better oh yeah yeah
sons I think that's the one magmar you
look like some sort of duck mutant
monster that glom gold tried to make in
ducktales to steal Scrooge McDuck's gold
I would believe it should I go with the
two that are relatively close or the big
group now I think the two that are like
head-butting is is like great behavior
shot that's yeah that's got pokey
personality yeah go with this there we
go they are loving it there there lady a
lady in the tramping each other is
what's happened to you really are yeah
that's the one that's the Charmeleon oh
well I guess I think the right side this
side yeah this awkwardly frame shot it
don't think he's gonna notice that the
face is cut off well we'll see if you
know it is a full frontal it is well
we're gonna learn more about Professor
Oak's proclivities here and the ole oak
check we're gonna find out to Professor
Oak all right let me know what you think
oak man Professor Oak's check volcano
course rapidash cryo thinks doesn't know
it says I don't think I ever ran out of
film in this game well you clearly have
a lot more patience than i do
3220 not bad for a first shot ready so
pics 640 good pose though great pose oh
my goodness 30 to 80 yeah wonderful what
does that bonus 54 for there's an extra
vulpix like I got you barely in the back
magmar EML 1594 in the game spot comment
says certain structures line up in the
shape of pokemon like there's one at the
start of the beach like as you're going
they like home in the shape of a Pokemon
this game does have a lot of Easter eggs
in it including literal Easter eggs like
the one that we've knocked into the lava
and out came a glorious Phoenix mm-hmm a
cable trays alrighty is that evolved
small dose I get 50 points for majestic
Phoenix type Pokemon soaring into the
air come on those sickos doesn't like it
from behind he's really on mr. oak I
must have suffered some traumatic from
behind experience in his you it looks
happy ah intern max says don't throw
apples at the egg next time and you'll
get stuck and you can just get a ton of
charm Anders just really go to town on
some char man just really Charmander
overload yeah i'll give you an extra 400
10 points wyd our foal not bad
Charmeleon this is a chore marion oh
yeah look at this technique perfect
Charizard how was the size sizes pretty
good okay he's gonna he's gonna like it
like says he doesn't mind that he's
[ __ ] totally not can't see right this
is like an NSA pic yeah where they've
like cut off the top of the image
wonderful wonderful wait jerk let's
return to the lab do you think I
unlocked a new thing welcome back
welcome back you are doing a footjob
jerk choose good to course I think that
we are having we're having some
strategic arguments going down in the
chat okay we're Luna 9 says ignore the
charm Anders the fighting mag Mars on
the other side is a better shot okay now
we have unlocked a new course so I feel
like that's all a bit of a moot point
yeah we're going to the river yeah I'll
go to the river we're not going to
repeat volcano here we don't have that
much time left on the stream and
professor oak is just doing his squats
in the corner yeah that guy has really
muscular thighs yeah the size of tree
trunks all right in the river what come
on down Oh magic carpet search there's a
magic carpets gonna come out every
single time alright this is gonna be a
good shot on the right oh wait no the
trees come on come on jump up jump
squiggly sword nailed it poliwag oh is
that a Bulbasaur that looks like a
Bulbasaur on out of there come on out of
there boba albany trucking no apples how
about you piece of garbage well yeah
that's a great Bulbasaur [ __ ] you
Bulbasaur yeah oak is gonna hate that
what up slowpoke boom
it's looking dumb as hell who stop stop
abusing them and take more pictures yet
throw it onto the dirt right that way
where the book was sitting Psyduck huh
get a picture of the hallucinogenic
mushroom one question why you gotta get
it to come out where's this psyduck more
signed over look down river you think I
need more magic car pics I've already
got so many magic car pics I'm allows
you got a jacquard a ton of Magikarp I'm
gonna beam that Metapod take that
Metapod all right look down you're not
gonna get a side up oh there is Psyduck
he's coming back around get a better
shot Psyduck get back here Anton and
Todd for those who don't know Anton is
the German name of psyduck don't ask us
why we know that get the thing get that
get that a horrible thing that always
abomination of nature yeah get that off
dad oh whoa that our mollusk that was a
good shot of Terror mollusk get dead hmm
ooh look on the bottle under nope it's
not do you think i have to like throw it
more precisely no I think you probably
have to get like a button presser
extension no I open if you're not on a
surfboard you can just GTFO Pikachu
that's all too if you're not gonna shred
better get out of here okay there's
another secret passage yep sure just
take a car pick yeah for no good goddamn
reason here we go that kid is determined
that is back to the lab woof that is
exhausted that was a real barn burner
I'm not gonna lie i'm mentally and
emotionally fatigued after that
and emotionally for them but I just
really drained you did we're gonna go
with this poliwag nice what is that's a
big old slowpoke that's a monster
slowpoke big time poking all right yeah
yeah sure it bulbasaur that that's like
just a big fu to Professor Oak yeah fe
you professor actually maybe go for the
double trouble I don't know the size
isn't as good here we go that's a good
one yep got to get one with two ocean
that's pretty solid although he's kind
of kind of off-center I feel like no let
me go at this one it's so real Sophie's
Choice it is it is just like that movie
Sophie's Choice yeah in which some I
think a woman named sophie has to make a
real tough choice yeah kind of a tough
choice not like a super tough choice or
is it a Solomon's choice homans choice
it's someone's I don't like tasters
choice okay which sit with shot is
you're gonna hate the worst you Holly
wag or your Bulbasaur let's play back
was a 173 Shia worst shot of the day 30
points cuz Bulbasaur only had his bulb
he's like the tip of his bulb exposed
now this slowpoke is really gonna
salvage this run I think so I think it's
gonna be a solid so slow poke a
technique is [ __ ] and the twitch chat
has devolved into people just calling
each other squirtles yours although to
be fair I think that's our production
team instigating
Psyduck ah that's a good side up doc why
not fall okay we've got time for one
more run before we finish [ __ ]
Professor Oak's gauntlet of beach tunnel
volcano river vote you guys to it Chet
you're gonna decide go now Beach tunnel
volcano river let's find out how's the
pose dental what TenPoint pose it's
phone it was counting the one in the
center on the right because OS is a real
Neanderthal when it comes to judging
photos if I get 1760 more points on my
Bookman report I'll get something cool
why do you keep saying that like some
sort of weird Russian word cuz that's
what it is there's no vowels in it pkmn
babe what are we thinking all right Oh
getting a lot of volcanoes volcano is a
good one yeah mmm looking like volcano
definitely volcano alright this is our
last run let's see if it's any good
volcano time alright yeah what was the
magmar one or the magnet or something I
don't know you want to get your cheer
your suggestions out there you better do
it immediately and not for the stuff
that's happening right now oh yeah get
him boys all right throw em into the
thing into the lava into their thing
yeah Jaya dash cauldron I don't tell me
what to do I know what I'm doing what
need you even ask me on the street
hahahaha Paul Kane Owen doing max is
saying don't throw stuff at the egg all
right okay keep the egg there wow I wish
you would stop committing suicide these
Volvox I mean
native vulpix population just plummeted
as soon as oak introduced his three
wheel bucket and apple shaped pokemon
food yeah it's in here what's in this
lava huh pokemon food now Chuck apples
from do to me oh it's whoa or fig out
Charmin oh look at that true oh my
goodness you just oh you made me just
involved you made a big mistake on their
fighting this looks lewd wow yeah wow
you ever seen a picture of a mag mart
given a charmeleon a blow jibber cuz
you're just humping magners bed no no
remorse no it's it's something else
something else well when to fire pokemon
alright other very Charmander wanting to
throw them up the hill right and then
they'll know they're coming down come on
guys over here this way let's go
Charmander party what's just everyone
bunk get charm guys get chart over here
yeah throat real close you gotta lure
I'm real close oh my goodness yeah oh
this is gonna eat Oh turn around though
too many butts for this oak is so mad
yeah they're all look in your direction
all right you're good we're good we
don't want to blow it on the charizard
pic later we are gonna get this there we
go nice trace Moltres come back Moltres
I'll come back involve it yeah yeah
evolved into mole Quatro Quatro mult
Cinco is my favorite
magmar you are a real piece of [ __ ] type
Pokemon we're not gonna lie to you
you're cool wow it's that other magmar
another magmar that you were chucking
apples that way to sow discord in the
magmar community anything good in here
is it just gonna be a dumbass Magikarp
yeah yep right on cue magic car all
right here we go I got 19 shots left for
this Charmeleon what get is gonna [ __ ]
car all right get it bonk yeah all here
it is nice okay he's gonna blow fire
your face yeah yeah oh it's so good yeah
spew that flame all over Professor Oak's
stupid hover boat wheel thing you're
gonna not even a protective dome on that
thing like that what a friggin dome I
guess I would be able to throw a breast
yeah you got scorched I got big town
fire breath go see Professor Oak after
you go to the intensive burn unit all
right I just want to see how that
Charizard picture turned out skipping
straight to char's are really you don't
want to you don't want to come on we got
it you got to get some points cuz you
got to unlock something cool all right
sure that's a good one that's a good
rapey dash I don't think these vulpix
azhar gonna be better than my old vulpix
is your vulpix pics yes
yeah show them the humping one I think
he'll really enjoy that no yeah yeah
yeah that one reopen mag Mars dome yeah
that's a good one it's too far away in
those already there's gonna be some good
Charmander ones here I think this is
probably the winner yeah there are no
buts and as we cuz we all as we all know
locates butts what's the one before it
cuz the size is much better but I think
that's the blood yeah there's a lot of
but going on in that one alright let's
see I think this is the way yeah that's
pretty good yeah and it's got a good
amount of screen tearing in it too
that's perfect Professor Oak is super
stoked about screen tearing all right
intern max says well done whoa I can
only presume he's talking to you and not
someone who made a good joke and it's
which okay he's definitely talking to me
yeah I think this is gonna be better the
size is definitely better yeah hose nuts
good but still ahead on points yeah net
improvement well well duh whoohoo what
do you think of that mag mar all right I
need Professor Oak I need you to
appreciate the context of this photo
there's a dramatic pose happening mad
Mars being assaulted by this Charmeleon
or alternatively or alternative watching
some cross-species contact pose the pose
got better points code of course yeah
yeah cuz he's getting blasted by that
Jimmy Liam hey he really is yeah he
gives you points oh and may just want /
just piss you weren't closer to it yeah
that's true all right oh I'm definitely
gonna save this one
Charmander yeah but it's not as good
it's definitely not as good deceit
slamming you on the sides whoa x 6 that
F how for photo yeah there are other
Charmander char Manders plural you can
pluralize it it's okay do that Wow still
not as good Wow oak you are inscrutable
Barnes Ruby alright let's see how this
Moltres did it solid size poses gotta be
way better oh yeah what a wonderful pose
I'm up your best pose score yet well
well duh moon little italy literally and
you top the post scorer on this one ice
is not as good i would beg to differ
seriously leaning in closer face is huge
that's a good flame though you know as a
technique yeah technique is flawless
double down
what do you think I earned I don't know
jerk let's return to the lab quick jerk
to the lab you take pictures at a good
pace to make your work easier here is a
present for you it will come in handy
for taking Pokemon pictures it's the
pastor ball it's easy press B when you
are not focusing your camera this will
make hidden Pokemon come out into the
open it's the pester ball yeah just go
ahead into the pokemons natural habitat
litter it with these balls that annoy
the [ __ ] out of them and then take
photos damn it oak classic oh ah I think
some real issues with this guy's
methodology but that was pretty fun
that's well that's an issue for another
day it is pokemon snap is a video game
that if you really enjoyed what you
played you can spend way too much money
on it on Virtual Console ten dollars on
Wii Virtual ten dollars yeah well I mean
five of those i think is the sweet spot
yes clearly there's a lot of you folks
with serious nostalgia and like
knowledge like deeply seated sense
memory of this game yeah and we're all
the pokemons are so you get you can
plate if you've gotta with you that
brought about with you probably few have
a week you have a week yeah because this
will you is emulating a wii in order to
play it so deftly work on your week
anyways that's it for this episode of
the Shan method next week we are
continuing video game history month
uh-huh with do you know I forget you
don't even know I already decided here
so now your brightness Oh Shenmue we're
playing Shenmue for the drill yeah
forklift stuff all day I've actually
never played that game piece uh in two
hours we got the lobby oh yeah we're
gonna be playing some Wolfenstein the
new order okay Greg Miller from I jeans
coming by to play an old classic
ghostbusters this bus gonna check out
some titanfall talk about transistor
review and are you going to play
transistor no we did that last week with
Greg cassava yeah
I want to that demo was cool you want to
watch that demo before the lobby in two
hours cool but we'll see you back here
in two hours but lobbying because we're
giving away stuff too sounds good prices
alright everybody thank you for watching
and we will see you next week on the
Shan method at 11am Pacific so long bye